I just thought Captain America Civil War
it was the best Marvel movie I've ever
seen I got friends here
Andrew Andrews family Courtney
Toni and more friends we're gonna review
Captain America Civil War on IMAX the
classic Chinese Theater we're before
they only allowed Chinese people to come
in it was only trying to strive to be
the best possible picture of sound
presentation using the newest the most
innovative in cinema technology and that
tradition confused with a stream of
Civil War and I nights with laser 3d
you're about to experience unparalleled
color contrast brightness and 12 channel
IMAX surround sound
[Music]
the audience lost their [ __ ] the whole
time it was that movie was hands-down
the most exciting Marvel movie I've seen
in a long time
and it's probably the best Marvel movie
I've ever seen everything that you've
heard people say about why it's great
trust me it is exactly as good as
everyone makes it out to be for Stark I
don't even there's so much in this movie
it's like what are you really what I
love too is the concept of when they of
why they're having this fight you know
you see that it's more than just logical
reasons as to why they're having sighs
you see like Tony's personal situation
with us you see Captain America's
personal involvement in this Civil War
that's gauntlets forming beyond that
it's just freaking it's just an awesome
adventure and it's jam-packed with
characters but it's the first book comic
book movie I've seen where it's
jam-packed with characters and yet it
all works perfectly the characters the
characters are great everyone gets their
equal opportunity to shine yes it's
still a Captain America film at the end
of the day but it's
I'm shocked I'm so enjoy by howlite and
I was so enthusiastic during this whole
movie I was so genuinely surprised by
how excited I was the entire time I was
watching this film like yes the action
is without a doubt [ __ ] incredible
and that airport scene that everyone
keeps talking about was probably the
best Hollywood fight I've ever seen in
any of these movies this movie overall
takes a pretty serious tone but it
definitely doesn't lacking Homer and all
the humor comes naturally like age of
Ultron I kind of felt like the humor was
a little hoarse here it's like it all
just comes very much out of the
characters voices this is the best
performance I've seen a lot of the
Marvel characters ever I mean you got to
see a much darker side to Tony Stark the
whole time Captain America I thought
this was the best portrayal cap we've
ever gotten
I really like what they did with Bucky
like they they took this character who's
you know not exactly the most likable
dude and they've turned him into a
character that I can really get on board
for and people have been complaining a
little bit about the Marvel villains not
being that great even in this one like
the ultimate villain to this film I like
what they did with him I thought he was
a villain with a personal motive and I
like what his motives were and I thought
it was different than what we normally
get if you've been a Marvel fan or if
you still are if you about the Marvel
movies this movie just nails it down
perfectly to the point where each and
every character in this film there's so
many of them more than the Avengers and
yet it just felt like everyone really
shined in this movie one thing I really
like too about the foam is that
deals a lot with like the Brotherhood
and the themes of like you know family
themes as well and just it was
speechless right now one thing I really
liked you is that the fight scenes all
they felt like there was a purpose
behind them it felt like it was every
fight scene felt personal every fight
scene felt it didn't feel like oh this
is just cool to look at because the you
know Marvel characters are here it was
always like a real strong reason for
them to fight okay now that I'm in the
car I could probably get my thoughts
better together organized nope they're
not there's so much going on in this
movie there's so many plot twists
there's so many character turns there's
so many there's so many characters yet
everything is so like well-balanced like
throw the script was so damn good that
you're able to like really just get on
board and keep up with everything that's
going on even though there's so much
happening scarlet which was great I
loved how they advanced her I mean
elizabeth Olsen is still sounds like
she's doing an American accent for most
of it I don't really hear the Russian
side too much I like what they did with
vision they actually made him like
funnier like Falcon a lot I thought this
was the best Falcon we've ever gone and
the appearances that we saw they were
never shoehorn into the film like it
wasn't just like oh we gotta include
this character now you know just because
it's gonna look great for a trailer or
something and the trailers we saw that
ant-man's in here Paul Rudd
I really thought did a fantastic job
what's great about these like characters
they put in there is there they seem
necessary to the plot they're more than
just a fun treat for us to have like
they they actually advance the story
forward more and they set up you know
other movies as well I mean yeah we all
saw in the trailer we've been seeing how
spider-man's in here and Tom Holland
regardless of the fact that he only
recognized Tyrone Magnussen ami when I
met him he still did a fantastic job the
audience just lost their [ __ ] over and
not just cuz he's spider-man but because
he's really really good as spider-man
I'm excited to see his standalone movie
it was trippy seeing spider-man on the
screen on it's like just to finally see
him be a part of the MCU
was it was kind of surreal every time he
was there but damn was he good in like
his delivery of all the lines and and
the fight scenes the course of
spider-man were great they still matched
its hell a Captain America story but
provide us with a huge in Samba peace
as well I mean Hawkeye is great in it oh
man I just all I could keep saying is
how great this film is and it's hard
it's hard to explain why it's so damn
good without giving away stuff just know
that it takes you on an adventure it's
got awesome acts some of the best action
I've seen in any of these Marvel any
comic book movie really and it's from
the same guys who did Winter Soldier and
Winter Soldier was a pretty serious film
I like that the script here was very
serious but I love how the humor really
comes out of the characters it doesn't
come out of forcing in jokes it was
really cool what they did with black
panther because they they actually gave
him like a real story in this film they
gave him a real important character he
was more than just you know oh it's cool
to see black panther in his suit
fighting and stuff like you're on board
for this really like rather serious dude
the whole time the trailers were it felt
like maybe they were revealing a little
too much and then when I was watching
the movie I was like well this scene in
the trailer hasn't happened yet but the
film always managed to surprise me even
with scenes that I'm like like okay for
example that scene that we see in the
trailer where Bucky and cap are like
fighting iron man so the whole purpose
behind that I can't give it away but it
was like man if they made that fight
really [ __ ] personal and it made it
that much more intense I just really
liked how personal everything felt this
was this was a very personal tale this
was beyond just some cool
action-adventure flick getting a bunch
of heroes together this was an essential
anger - yeah [ __ ] Marvel Man they
know
so yeah I mean I know this reviews like
all over the place I was just I was so
excited when I was watching the movie
like I was genuinely like very giddy
during a lot of these sequences because
it was just such a fun time and yeah
it's it's also like really gritty
methought it spritely the most violent
one we've seen out of the MCU yet like I
said it doesn't lose a sense of humor
it's it's just an awesome event it's
hands down one of the best comic book
movies I've ever seen and I yeah I'm
just really in shock by just how much I
loved this film I was expecting to like
it I was expecting to like it a lot I
wasn't expecting to be like wow that was
I was better than the Avengers like that
was really [ __ ] good kudos to you
guys and I'm excited for the Avengers
infinity war for the Russo Bros to do
that anyway guys yeah I'm probably gonna
be doing a spoiler talk with John
sometime soon and you can subscribe
today this was a little bit different I
just really wanted to talk about the
movie immediately and I guess this video
is over
it's done
cutting a black
never II was so awesome I can't stop
thinking about it